[Musique]
quand on dit que le franc français
malade et ben vous voyez bien que c'est
la vérité mais cela doit vous avez un
billet de 50 francs
on ne les crasses pas la pulpe des
légumes remarquer le va conserver
véritablement la totalité de son jeu je
rappelle que le jus de concombre
contient une très très grande quantité
de collagène le collagène est
extraordinaire pour la le prix apparaît
douze celui-ci la parité vendu 85 francs
le grand manège blanc sans trop de noirs
150 francs et accessoires
il n'en reste pas moins de voilà un
billet qui a retrouvé ses couleurs
il n'a pas retrouvé sa valeur d'avant
guerre mais les couleurs avant la tâche
pourquoi c'est largement suffisant
laisser macérer macedonio ou fat comme
ma grand mère
on commence bien sûr comme ça c'est vrai
après c'est comme ça après c'est comme
ça
et après comme ça alors il n'est pas
parce que quand vous le faites briller
plus ça vient pas les états unis ça
vient pas de hong kong
ça c'est français pour acheter français
messieurs dames 1 c'est quand même un
appareil sensationnel et ce qui ne gâche
rien à mon idée alors qu'il y à 2
millions de chômeurs en france c'est un
produit français
on va faire comme les vaisseaux on va
marcher pourra pas faire semblant
44e quand même on va piétiner et on va
être bien faire pénétrer les poires les
filles les plus jolies pierres à
l'intérieur de la trame du tap et à
l'intérieur de n'être guère là l'élu qui
de vous dire quand tout est bien tassé
pour la phase souviendra le tango
argentin le derby et d'irriguer les
buckets marmottan des sources il y
aurait alors on fait pas semblant de 85
kilos de graisse paramus que tu tires
avec des élastiques les années un joli
chapeau mesdames une encolure parfaite
un foulard qui sera toujours bien fixée
vous les reprenez de l'autre côté temps
des biens neufs ou la remontée est fixé
c'est la pureté la clarté la labilité
extraordinaire de ce jus de légumes dans
le vert il n'y a pas à boire et à manger
il y a que les vitamines et les sels
minéraux et là arrêtez moi si je me
trompe car il paraît que c'est laid
monstre à tort c'est des menteurs nuance
c'est des baratineurs tom frotte et
maintenant voilà un produit végétal
naturel sans aucun composant chimique
transformer et ce qui d'après moi ne
gâche rien un produit français messieurs
dames hd france est un
peut-être même que celle à venir nos
enfants sont dépensés du chômage dans la
boue un comme sauter résistance
l'appareil est posé et l'adieu pleymo
mieux tes commentaires regarder via
d'avion laine des amis n'appuyez pas ne
forcez pas un époux cirage en profondeur
on utilisera par exemple et jude oignons
pour sclérosé les varices les jus de
chouf pour filtrer les reins et un jeu
extraordinaire messieurs dames c'est le
jus de la carotte notamment pour la
croissance des enfants
je prends les chèques bancaires les
chèques postaux les chaque endroit
gentil à 130 francs si ça vous intéresse
je vous fais les deux modèles pour 240
francs les modèles ou alors je vous fais
les deux modèles pour 280 et bien
messieurs dames pour les quelques
personnes qui sont là si vous achetez
ces deux-là au prix marquées de 50
francs ou ces deux là vous pouvez payer
par chèque si vous le voulez le
troisième il est gratuit et le quatrième
est gratuit également
[Musique]